really loved that movie you know I did
how did it end up doing for you
financially like like you put nothing
but uh and I do want to shout out my
producer the guy that produced bad trip
Dave Burnett is in the hallway uh White
load Emmy award-winning White Lotus
producer Dave bernad saved bad trip from
Peril over and over again and I want to
give him his roses and his praise thank
you Dave he's 10 feet away from me so no
I remember how much work you put into
that thing and I thought it was really
funny but and you ended up releasing it
in theaters right it was yeah because no
it was about to go out in theaters
but yeah supposed to premiere March 2020
at South by Southwest covet happened the
world shut down then it was nowhere then
MGM was secretly trying to sell it to
quibby behind our backs I don't know if
you remember quibby it was a streaming
service that lasted for three minutes
and uh and then they got caught with
their and they kept telling us Netflix
didn't want it real then Dave who saved
the day sent it to they sent it to the
wrong person at Netflix which is insane
and then Dave sent it to the right
person Netflix was like this is amazing
we love this and it was the number one
movie in the world number one movie in
the U.S was it it deserved it yeah
and uh I made
um
zero dollars I made I made the minimum
sag after Indie scale the movie took
seven and a half years to make and I
made like I probably like netted 17 000
books
unbelievable story decade of work David
and Jeff Germaine made zero dollars
because it wasn't a theatrical release
but number one movie in the world how
many years seriously in terms of like
you thinking about it wanting to do it
them writing it and then going out and
making it that shit's a lot of work yeah
it was it was almost eight years we
watched Bad Grandpa Jeff tremaine's
first like narrative prank movie with
Knoxville in October 2013 and we were
like early days of Eric Andre show we're
like we want to do that and then the
movie came out on Netflix March 2021 so
it was eight years in all seriousness
did you feel defeated I mean like were
you like oh yeah I mean I was
uh it was miserable man I was breaking
down I mean my dad found out he had
cancer the day we were supposed to
Premiere at South by Southwest it was
horrible I was it was dark days
beginning of quarantine I was just like
in a bathrobe every day drinking white
Russians I was like The Big Lebowski
just sitting on my couch staring at the
ground drinking white Russians just had
a bottle of vodka next to my coffee
table it was dark it was dark but you
know what the success of the movie has
opened other opportunities so as the
beginning it's the beginning of a new
chapter
foreign